what do you learn by doing
all the steps along the way and just for
people who don't know cross-color choke
from the mount
so you just starts in a neutral place
there's people on their feet and then
you either then you get to the ground
somehow and then there's the person on
top and on bottom and then there's a
guard with the legs between the two
people and then you can get past the
guard
as you get past the guard and you uh
into side control and so on you get more
and more and more dominant positions and
so Mount is considered to be one of the
most dominant positions it's when you're
past their legs sitting on top of their
stomach
putting pressure on them and cross
collar choke is using their jacket to uh
how would you explain that to children I
put my both hands on your collars and
when I squeeze you you press your neck
so it blocks the venue you go to sleep
so it's a you you choke people with your
hands in the wrist you put them you know
you grab the collar so you get the
wrists around people's neck can you
squeeze yeah the discovery of that is
fascinating I mean because it's it's
interesting it's like um
you know you can imagine there's all
kinds of ways to choke
a human being
what animals do with their like mouth
right they put like their jaws around
the
and the fact that you can kind of
discover this methodology of the right
kind of positioning and then it becomes
an art form like of why this why not
this right or why not this or something
like to figure out we practice that
would come easy over time you figure out
what works and what not on you and then
and then more further and further
details and subtleties start to emerge
anyway on that process of beating of
being able to beat some of the best
people in the world and the thing they
know is coming
what is what's the difference between
the white belt doing that and hydro
Gracie doing that the thing that's so
hard to explain what do you think you're
picking up is it some tiny tiny details
of muscle movements it is it's many tiny
details because
is is the whole movement itself is the
perception
from beginning to end like every step of
the movement it's important and precise
so it's you know you miss one one detail
on the way you collapse
so I'm going to start with the black
belt the black belt has no control over
the whole movement he's thinking
beginning and then
so he goes straight to you know straight
to your neck regardless he cannot read
the other person if his you know if it's
time to let go if it's the time to go
for a neck he should I be pushing here
before I get my hand in you know is is
this the right time to go deep or should
I deal with this first before the second
hand that's at the beginning says that
that the white belt yeah at the very
beginning of the journey yeah the white
belt you just think finish yeah
and then as you get progressed you see
that there's like this giant tree of
possibilities that you're almost feeling
your way down I mean would you be able
to teach
do you even know what you're doing by
the details okay
but it's hard to convert into words
probably uh no that's possible then you
don't know what you're doing okay uh
so what is what what is the most
important details
they could say maybe positioning of the
hand the gripping is it the positioning
of your body the posture is there some
interesting like insights It's a
combination because first you have to
put your body in a very strong position
that you don't require your hands to
hold them out
so the choke is that that's first
because
I cannot you I cannot use my hands on
the floor to stop you escaping yeah so
if I have to my body has to handle that
the way I position myself I have to do
it in a way that don't require my hands
for balance